I think there's a lot of existential
angst and psychedelics have for
Millennia represented hope in transition
moments Erica dick is a professor at the
University of Saskatchewan who studies
the history of psychedelics with a
special interest in the legacy of
Humphrey Osmond the british-born
psychiatrist who coined the term
psychedelic gave Aldous Huxley his first
dose of mescaline and conducted
path-breaking work using LSD to help
alcoholics stop drinking among Osmond's
best-known patients was Bill W the
co-founder of Alcoholics Anonymous
reason sat down with dick at the
Psychedelic science 2023 Conference held
in Denver this June where a reported 13
000 people gathered to talk about all
aspects of today's psychedelic
Renaissance we talked about why drugs
such as MDMA psilocybin and LSD are
making a comeback how tensions are
rising between indigenous people and
medical practitioners and whether
prohibitionists have finally lost the
War on Drugs
[Music]
what does the Psychedelic renaissance
mean to you
I'm a historian who's been studying the
psychedelics for over 20 years and so
the Psychedelic Renaissance is actually
kind of a confusing term because it's
quite new and yet it invokes this sort
of deep history and this really deep
cultural transformation and uh as a
historian I guess I'm a little bit
nervous about that as to whether or not
we've really reached that point where we
can call this a Renaissance moment but
I'm also really curious about what it
means in terms of what we're trying to
revive and what we're trying to
resurrect from the past that might be
worthwhile in terms of sort of charting
a psychedelic future and I think there's
Rich opportunity to think about some of
the different ways that psychedelics and
psychedelic thinking has really come to
Bear meaning in this historical moment
well let's talk about the you know LSD
was synthesized in 1938 uh you know
started getting used about 60 years ago
right 43 whatever I'm an English major
yeah
um you know but then in the 50s and 60s
there was this first moment where
psychedelics were being used in a wide
variety of contexts for a wide variety
of reasons what are the lessons that we
should be learning from that moment
yeah this kind of Awakening moment when
the word psychedelic is first coined and
kind of coalesces around a variety a
variety of medical experimentation is
this Awakening moment I think for
psychedelics in the 20th century
and yet there were lots of challenges in
that moment prior to the kind of
counter-cultural uptake of these
substances as well challenges in how to
measure experience whose experiences
matter who should we draw those
experiences from whether it's indigenous
communities or midwives or even
spiritualists and people working on
paranormal questions with respect to
psychedelics and I think we haven't
really answered that question and then
as psychedelics moved underground those
questions lay dormant and there's a
tendency I think to kind of push against
the past and suggest that you know now
we're doing it Anew or in a fresh way
but I like the concept of Renaissance
that also reminds us to think about what
we missed in the past and maybe
resurrecting some of those pieces so I
think that kind of wild landscape for
experimentation of the 1950s is
something we should embrace here again
can you talk about a Humphrey Osmond
who's the guy who coined the term
psychedelic
um you know skipped around the globe
ended up in Canada where he was doing a
lot of this work what is his
contribution or what is his role to the
Psychedelic I guess moment in the 50s
but then what should we be learning from
him now
Humphrey Osmond is such a fascinating
character you know not only for deeply
investing in the word itself psychedelic
which is you know to bring light to the
psyche or delos to bring to light we
introduce it in 1956 by saying to Fathom
hell or sore Angelic you'll need a pinch
of psychedelic the first uttering of it
it's like an advertising jingle it is a
bit and he played around with this
concept and you can find different Ramen
couplets online and Aldous Huxley his
friend came up with his own sort of
matches but you know I think when I
interviewed Humphrey Osmond in the early
2000s the conversation around
psychedelics was quite different at that
time and you know he wasn't getting his
phone wasn't ringing off the hook
but you know I asked him what his sort
of proudest moment was or what he
thought his legacy might be and these
are always awkward questions for people
I think at the best of times but
what he told me was surprising he said
that he was really proud of helping to
found schizophrenics anonymous
and I've been reflecting on that for
some time and wondered whether this was
because he didn't want to talk about
psychedelics in that moment because they
were considered taboo but I actually
think there's more to it I think that
for him like his good friend Aldous
Huxley who wrote doors of perception
psychedelics really were a doorway they
were a tool and something he felt helped
us to think differently about a whole
variety of problems
for him co-founding schizophrenics
anonymous was seeing some kind of
dignity in what we today might call
neurodiversity
and finding peer groups and investing in
communities that could think about that
was an enduring Legacy of psychedelics
for him
I think there's something really
powerful in reflecting on that and
thinking about what psychedelics have to
offer us today whether it's simply
getting them across a regulatory line so
that they can become medicines or
whether by thinking with psychedelics we
might actually think differently about
human behavior and neurodiversity and
tolerance of all kinds
um yeah expand a little bit on that what
do you you know what does it mean to
you know use psychedelics is it a way to
model different states of kind of normal
human consciousness so that we instead
of saying okay there's here there are
three ways of doing it right now there's
a hundred
yeah I think I I mean Osmond was
criticized for investing in what he
thought of as a model psychosis by using
masculine and later LSD and then later
again
at the time sometimes they were called
psychotomimetics exactly so mimicking
psychosis and and he wrote about that
quite extensively in the early 1950s
suggesting that
um that staff should be taking
psychotomimetics that staff should be
experiencing what he described as kind
of an empathetic pathway or a way to
empathize with their patients we've got
to remember that in the 1950s throughout
much of the western world
patients with schizophrenia were in
institutions and here he was the
superintendent of one of the largest
institutions in western Canada with 4
000 patients and just over 2 000 beds so
he was dealing with this Herculean task
of trying to reform Psychiatry and for
him trying to understand those patients
who he felt were difficult to connect
with was a really huge insight
so I think that connects with why he
thinks this is part of the enduring
Legacy
why do you think psychedelics are having
such a moment right now
I think that there is a a cultural
searching for some kind of answers and
if we want to think about it in terms of
mental health and unwellness
we've seen a lot of investment in
psychiatry in psychopharmacology in
mental health the mental health industry
if you will and we have not seen a
corresponding decline in the burden of
mental health and disease around the
world they're actually running it you
know at sort of Crossroads yeah can I
ask do you think I mean is that kind of
an iatrogenic effect where it's like
well we have a lot more psychologists
and a lot more therapists so they need
work I mean are they creating make work
projects for themselves or is there an
actual observable increase of mental
illness
I think it's tempting to see this as an
iatrogenic problem that the more
psychiatrists we have the more problems
we have but I don't know what it's like
here in parts of the United States but
there are long wait lists to see
psychiatrists and there are major
problems in gaining access to mental
health professionals so I think I think
it's not as simple as as seeing it that
way
um somewhat unfortunately in many
respects but I think there's a
collective kind of existential crisis
going on in the 1950s there was a cold
war nuclear weaponry was just being
dispatched I mean I think there were
real existential reasons why people were
anxious and there was also a
corresponding increase in general wealth
too absolutely people were bumping up
hierarchy of needs absolutely
um so what you know
um so how how do psychedelics play into
this current moment which in some ways
then reflects a kind of 1950s mentality
people are worried about the end of the
world for X Y and Z reasons people have
a lot of money many people have more
time on their hands than they used to
because work is easier et cetera how do
psychedelics help help us now or how
should we think about them in this
context
I think psychedelics again represent
that kind of lusting after some kind of
curiosity something that helps us think
outside of the Orthodox box or think
outside the Orthodoxy and whether
psychedelics become a medicine or a way
to think with a tool a doorway I think
they represent a kind of hopefulness
right now in a moment when people are
grieving from the world being on fire
and a pandemic ravaging the globe I
think there's a lot of existential angst
and psychedelics have for Millennia
represented hope in transition moments
and I think it's now merging with our
Western cultural sensitivities around
that kind of searching quality that we
have
um you know so Osmond and
um Aldous Huxley had one vision of who
should who should be administering and
who should be receiving psychedelics in
the 60s you know between people like
Timothy Leary and Ken keese and others
that kind of got radically democratized
from a kind of you have more or less
priest class or you know clinician class
giving patients something to now let's
everybody should be doing it and
everybody has a right to do it
um how did that you know how did how did
that shift in the 60s play out to a
point where the Psychedelic research
kind of went dark for a couple of
decades yeah I think psychedelic
research went dark for a couple of
different reasons one of which was the
the infighting within the scientific
community and efforts to try to Define
how best to evaluate the risk profile of
psychedelics and this plays Into The
Counter Culture in interesting ways
because you have other figures like
Timothy Leary and Ken keezy who are you
know they play a different role in terms
of democratizing or liberalizing access
to psychedelics but they do it in a way
that we might consider quite Reckless
that abandons these concerns for safety
that does not necessarily consider the
ethics of whether or not you want to
take that much acid at a Grateful Dead
concert or with those people and so you
have these two extremes and I think they
come together to produce a kind of Epic
clash a clash of values but also a clash
of of trust trust in Social Capital if
you are trusting the underground
suppliers or trust in the scientific
Community to determine whether or not
these are safe substances and that's all
within the Psychedelic community and
then you know do you do you buy the
narrative that you know then you know so
there's that happening within
psychedelics but then the outside world
in the form of governments and whatnot
comes in and just says like okay it's
all over
yeah I think there's a lot of really
interesting work being done now from you
know lots of Scholars are looking at the
prohibition narrative and unpacking the
War on Drugs to suggest that in fact
this is a ruse that this was a war on
people a war on poverty a war on race
and and I think there's lots of good
evidence emerging to suggest that there
are some pretty clear lines that you
know certain communities were policed
more heavily and now this is where the
adage comes in that the more police you
have the more crimes you might find and
certainly by dispatching police into
certain communities lots of people went
to jail for what we might see today is
fairly Petty drug crimes and I think
that contributed to some of the the kind
of disparities that we see in some of
the Folly of that prohibition narrative
that doesn't really add up so Osman died
in 2004 right
um and you you were talking about
speaking with him you know right around
that time and psychedelics were still
kind of held in you know low repute uh
you know what has happened what's
changed change so that they're now you
know there's you know Ten Thousand
Eleven thousand people at this
conference you know there are movies and
TV shows and best-selling books about
psychedelics everybody's micro dosing
what what what happened
I think there's a couple of different
things that have led to this upsurge in
interest in psychedelics since it's
prohibition and kind of dying out
already you know recognized in the 1980s
and whatnot and and I think one is the
poking holes and the War on Drugs uh
we've seen this a lot with cannabis
reforms we've seen a number of Lobby
efforts to try to pull back that curtain
a little bit and change the script on
what's dangerous and what's okay to take
we also have a Western World at least
that has been introduced to pharmacology
in a dramatic way everybody has taken
some kind of pharmaceutical we have a
different kind of drug literacy and I
think if Marshall mcluhan were here he
would have a lot to say about the global
Network that we live in with social
media and the internet now you and I can
share our favorite stories or our
favorite recipes for sharing information
about psychedelics across time and space
in a way that was unimaginable in the
1960s and I think this is all also
created a kind of cultural upsurge of
interest in psychedelics that can't be
policed in the same ways
you are really sticking to the Canadians
aren't you invoking mcluhan did you like
that I just planted that in there I was
going to say something about Wayne
Gretzky but I hope yeah Mark Messier
though claims that uh mushrooms was
really what made him an excellent hockey
player I can talk hockey if you need me
to yeah I don't know but you know I
don't know if I haven't been a long time
no that's funny
um you
know I mean to actually keep in this
vein
um you know Canada has a different
relationship to alcohol prohibition than
the United States does and also to
psychedelic and and other types of drugs
what is what's the status of
psychedelics in Canada at this point
currently in Canada psychedelics are
strictly prohibited yeah they continue
to be fully criminalized although of
course much like places like the United
States and a few other jurisdictions
there are clinical trials there are
special exemptions
um some of which are patient based and a
few others are physician initiated
Canada again similar to the U.S there's
a tortured history with uh Native Native
populations and Native populations often
are you know talked about as people who
started using these drugs and whatnot
how is that playing out in Canada and
how do you think that informs or should
inform discussions about psychedelics
being legalized or normalized
there's a lot of talk about the
indigenous roots of psychedelics and in
Canada although there are some examples
of what's now described as psychedelic
plants there's not as much of a rich
history as you find in a few other
places and so I think there's a
temptation to overplay this or even
romanticize it a little bit but I think
going forward regardless of the the
scale of use I think there are really
important lessons to be taken from when
we start thinking about harm reduction
if we sort of skip to the end and
imagine a world in which psychedelics
are being consumed legally or not
indigenous communities need to be part
of that conversation as we think about
harm reduction and Indigenous ideas
about addiction and use have to be
incorporated into that I think what are
what are the major benefits of a world
in which psychedelic use or psychic you
know psychedelics are normalized
major benefits of a world in which
psychedelics are legalized or normalized
let's say normalized
it's a big question I mean I think it
should uh probably cause us to think
differently about our traffic laws and
it may have to open up a whole variety
of different harm reduction
Communications maybe about guns and
bicycles but jokes aside I think you
know I think working with psychedelics
there there's a risk perhaps of taking
the magic out of the mushrooms by
regulating them too quickly as we've
heard Roland Griffiths warn us about
there's a risk in moving things through
and creating just another Marketplace
for another pharmaceutical and uh I
think there's more that psychedelics
have to offer if we let them take their
own pace and if we think about the way
that psychedelics might help us to
imagine different possibilities when it
comes to alleviating stress or welcoming
neurodiversity so are you are you
worried that psychedelics are being too
much put into a kind of medical model or
a therapeutic you know that they're a
therapeutic as opposed to something more
expansive
I think that psychedelics have a lot to
offer in the therapeutic context but I
think people are going to take
psychedelics outside of that therapeutic
context and there's a risk of
destabilizing their regulation or
keeping them sort of within that
mainstream conversation without
harmonizing these two aspects from the
beginning
what do you think are the major
impediments to a world in which
psychedelics are either normalized or
legalized or just more widely used
I think
some of the major impediments to
legalizing or regularizing psychedelics
I think it's hard to know just yet I
think there's a lot of speculation and
of course we use history to try to paint
those pictures of you know people
perhaps jumping off of buildings
although that was overplayed you know
people staring at the sun also
overplayed some of those risks that
become almost laughable now but there
were real risks too there are real
ethical questions to be considered here
and I think
we need to be really careful and
cautious about how we take these steps
forward before we have any real Clarity
on the kinds of risks that are at stake
talk a little bit more about
neurodiversity in a psychedelic context
what what it what do you mean by
neurodiversity and how do psychedelics
help us either kind of understand or
live with that or actually kind of
support it
even though
ideas of the model psychosis were later
abandoned and there was clear evidence
that psychedelics or LSD for example
does not produce a schizophrenic-like
state I think the idea that you could
empathize with someone going through a
psychotic episode was still a powerful
concept
or this idea that maybe there can still
be Humanity in thinking differently or
in having disorganized thoughts and
behavior I think there's still really
there are still a lot of lessons to be
gleaned there from the empathetic
Pathways and opening this up to thinking
about neurodiversity might be at a
radically different way of Imagining the
burden of mental health and illness
imagine if we thought neurodiversity
that people who think differently behave
differently was actually part of the
spectrum of humanity rather than the
spectrum of pathology imagine what that
would do for changing our Health Care
Systems or our interventions
I I don't think it's necessarily like a
simple answer but I think it's a kind of
a radical departure from the ways in
which we have been cleaving to a
reductionist model that tries to manage
deficits and disorders rather than
embrace them
um Osmond towards the end of his life to
stick on him you know was in
investigating what's called or what was
called parapsychology in this movement
broadly speaking there's you know
there's one way of think about it is
there's a couple of tracks right there's
the scientific materialist medical you
know research track and then there's the
super woo-woo like we are touching the
face of God is that
um is that tension
um a good thing a bad thing
um you know where and where do you fall
in those camps
yeah you know I like to think of myself
as an observer of these camps more than
a participant with one you know this is
the Canadian this is my pragmatism yeah
no no pacifist Mennonite
um
um but seriously you know I I think
there's a temptation to you know think
about funding structures if I want to
apply for a grants you know I need to
speak the language of the reviewers and
that typically you know means that I'm
going to move away from as you describe
the woo-woo or move away from some of
the new age ideas or some of the
parapsychology or some of the stuff that
seems beyond the pale and yet I think
there's information to be gleaned there
in their relationships to be built that
can nourish this conversation this this
movement or project if you will
um I don't think everything is going to
stick but I think by clinging to these
divisive categories we're going to miss
a lot
um and I'm not sure that our sort of
disciplinary divisions and silos have
served us well and certainly not in this
moment what
um
you know one of the factors that kind of
undermine
just the use or at least the interest in
psychedelics in the late 60s you
mentioned you know people jumping off
you know being taking LSD and supposedly
jumping off the buildings Diane link
ladder uh you know the students from
various universities who stared into the
sun until they burned out their eyes and
things like that is that kind of story
however real or however kind of
manufactured it is is that the type of
thing that would stop what we're seeing
now with psychedelics or what what do
you think would be the types of events
that would shut down all of the movement
towards psychedelics
to imagine what kind of story it would
take to stop psychedelics in its tracks
right now
there are lots of stories and we have
greater access to news media than ever
before in terms of pretty horrific
things that have happened with or
without psychedelics and lots of times
without psychedelics so it's hard to
imagine
the 2023 version of staring at the sun
you know or you know
some some equivalent to that
I I worry sometimes that psychedelics
might go off the rails by collapsing our
faith into particular individuals rather
than seeing this as a more Dynamic
movement
and I say that with some trepidation
because I don't want to suggest that
anybody has you know ultimate control
but it does strike me as interesting
that there are you know certain certain
characters and certain individuals who
are really sort of pushing this movement
and I think the movement is in need of
more diversity at this point who who are
those people like who are they
you know yeah this is you know it
doubles as a congressional investigation
name names
well I'm gonna I'm gonna back my way
into that answer by saying you know we
we recognize certain leaders from the
past whether those are the Humphrey
Osmonds and all this huxleys who are
described as somewhat elitist in some
respects or the Timothy learys who let
the genie out of the bottle or the Ken
keezy who never had the genie in the
bottle in the first place
when we fast forward to today and I
think there are some key interlocutor
figures along the way as well people
like Laura Huxley people like Stan Groff
we might think of the schulgens as you
know really important players who kept
the Psychedelic dream alive in some
respects and did the best they could in
the context they were working in and
today we have real champions of
psychedelics who've got very sort of
loud voices in this conversation
it'll be interesting to see how history
treats them whether they're considered
somebody like like a Michael pollen
would be one I'd say Rick doblin Rick
Dublin
Tim Ferriss Joe Rogan we have some loud
voices that uh and I you know Amplified
voices I should say not loud but uh
voices with a lot of social capital in
this field
um and some are to a greater and lesser
degree held in check by things like peer
review or controlled trial analogy and
yet the sort of Social Capital
accumulating is um is really interesting
because it kind of moves into new
territory it's not the same as trying to
measure the efficacy of psilocybin
through randomized controlled trial you
know uh Mike Tyson can tell Joe Rogan
what he thinks and he influences more
people than many of those scientific
studies ever will
um let's talk uh briefly about uh Bill W
and the intersection of psychedelics or
LSD in the late 50s and Alcoholics
Anonymous
um what what is the lesson to be learned
from that episode where Bill W the
founder co-founder of AA talked openly
and publicly within the AAA newsletters
and whatnot about how I'm taking LSD and
it's really helping me stay off of booze
and just become more interesting
um what what happened with that and what
is the lesson to be drawn from that type
of episode I think Bill Wilson's Legacy
with respect to psychedelics and
alcoholism is twofold one is that
despite being the last member the last
co-founder he broke the pledge of
abstinence to try psychedelics and found
it really helpful particularly for
overcoming difficult steps for staying
with the program that's key and I think
you know help to serve as a bit of a
role model model for trying this but the
other part was forging an association
with an avowed non-medical intervention
provided the addiction studies the LSD
or sorry the Psychedelic addiction
studies with an incredibly important
Community Partnership a non-medical
partnership
this optimized people's results they
stuck with a therapy and they stuck with
the follow-up and that integration
period cannot be under
um under emphasized I think that
partnership really helped to produce
those outrageous results that we saw
published the 70 to 90 success rates it
wasn't just psychedelics it was
psychedelics and group therapy
uh I guess to kind of go back to
celebrities or whatnot you know around
the same period you know there are the
well-known stories of Cary Grant people
like Esther Williams these golden age of
Hollywood movie stars who were you know
I guess in their 50s at the time
suddenly raving about psychedelics is
that analogous to what we see now when
you know at this conference Aaron
Rodgers the football player the American
football player talk uh you know is is
it similar
um you know and how important is that
kind of activity in normalizing
something that was a subculture
I think it's interesting to think about
the context of celebrity endorsements in
the 1950s I'm not sure that they carried
the same kind of Gravitas that we can
imagine today with the power of social
media and the speed and the the sort of
the pace of information that flows today
but nonetheless it's important that we
we know that Ethel Kennedy and Esther
Williams and Cary Grant were treated
some of whom were treated in Canada at
this place called Hollywood Hospital
named for the Holly Hawk bushes not for
Hollywood but it happened to be a
connection
um Can con and uh it played me I was
like I gotta say it
um I'm not sure that it traveled as much
and and in some ways there are stories
particularly emanating from Hollywood
hospital and actually from a number of
places along the Pacific Northwest where
some of the celebrities actually were a
bit quiet about it until later perhaps I
think as an attempt to retain the
Psychedelic status but we're quiet about
it at first in part because they didn't
want to admit their alcoholism or in
some cases other underlying disorders
that they felt would compromise their
careers as film stars
um is the shift from being a Counter
Culture or an underground culture to an
above culture the culture what are the
big risks involved because it seems like
psychedelics are coming you know they're
they're coming up from underground and
they're everywhere people are talking
about them every you know every other
candy bar has some kind of mushroom in
it you know
Etc like what you know what are what are
the what are the risks and what are the
benefits of that kind of shift
I'm really a bit suspicious or skeptical
I should say about the kind of joining
of underground and above ground
information and my impression so far is
that those two are not really joining
but they're still a bit at odds with one
another that there's a kind of sanitized
or above-ground production of knowledge
about psychedelics that carries a
different kind of weight than some of
the underground work and I think there's
a risk in separating those in part
because some of the underground work are
done by populations who have been
criminalized for a long time and who are
not included in trials and whose
evidence and experience is not
necessarily forming part of the standard
narrative
I think there's a risk of both
exacerbating the divisions but also not
integrating psychedelics into the
culture in a sustainable way if we
ignore the practices of those who've
been using it for decades can you put a
little bit more meat on those bones what
what are some of the groups that you're
you're talking about that are you know
so far underground you know and they may
never be allowed to be or be recognized
above ground
we've seen for decades women working as
underground therapists for example and
some of these knowledge Keepers if you
will or some of these voices are being
muted I think in the conversation they
didn't subscribe to particular trials
they were doing it all on their own
let's abandon that information and you
know sanitize it in some respects and I
think there's a risk there I think we've
also seen some tensions around
indigenous uses of psychedelics both in
terms of where psychedelics grow so the
Organics peyote fields for example as
well as indigenous religious practices
and the regulated religious practices
their tensions about what's authentic
what's romanticized what's appropriated
and I think you know sort of pushing
past beyond that I think we need to
reconcile with those issues before we
sort of
figure out how to regulate psychedelics
and then go back and reconcile those
divisions
final question have you used
psychedelics personally and if so what's
your favorite psychedelic
I have two cheeky answers for you okay I
defended my PhD in 2005 on the topic of
the history of psychedelics and I was
asked this question then and I was
already warned by my supervisor that if
I had taken psychedelics I shouldn't
tell anybody because this could
compromise my Integrity as a researcher
and so I told him as I walked up the
steps to my defense that I didn't inhale
and he seemed satisfied with this answer
to which I thought he has not read my
dissertation
what I learned from the schulgans was
when Alexander shulgin or Sasha shulgin
was asked this question which
psychedelic is your favorite he said
it's the one I haven't discovered yet
and that's always kind of it sort of
stuck with me as perhaps the one I
haven't tried yet or you know finding
that to me psychedelics represent a kind
of hopeful curiosity and so I'm going to
cheekily answer your question by not
answering your question
Erica dick thanks for talking
thanks very much
[Music]